-Good evening, everybody.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're all doing well.
And now, let's get to the news.
President Biden appeared
last night on an NBC special
celebrating Betty White and
then again on "Chicago Fire."
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump
reportedly told
his lawyer, Rudy Giuliani,
to ask
the Department
of Homeland Security
if they could legally seize
voting machines
from swing states.
Said Trump, "Wrong.
I never said legally."
That's right, after losing
the election in 2020,
former President Trump
reportedly asked
if Homeland Security could seize
voting machines in swing states.
And if you're wondering whether
or not that's evil,
let me point you to the word
"seize."
It's always evil when "seize"
is involved.
For example, you will hear
a villain say,
"Seize them, you fools!"
But you'll never, ever hear
anyone say,
"Hey, good news.
The mayor has seized
more funding for the arts."
It was reported yesterday that
some of
the Trump White House records
that were turned over
to the House committee
investigating the Capitol attack
had been ripped up
and taped back together.
And from the looks of it,
so had some of the witnesses.
Wow.
"What happened, Steve?"
"Oh, I fell in the shredder."
Former President Trump's
political team
announced yesterday that
he amassed over $120 million
in his war chest.
Or as he told the IRS,
$1.2 million.
You know, I told the monologue
writers this morning --
I said, "Remember, tonight,
David Letterman's going to
be here."
[ Cheers and applause ]
"So bring --
bring your 'A' game."
And to a person, every single
one of them said,
"That's today?"
In a new interview,
New Jersey Governor Phil Murphy
said that the state needs to,
quote,
"learn to live with
the coronavirus pandemic,"
not to mention melanoma.
"The New York Times" has
reportedly paid
in the low seven figures to
acquire
the daily word game, Wordle.
But I got it in six.
I was so happy.
I'm doing Wordle jokes.
They finally started to work.
[ Laughs ]
Producers have announced
a new prequel television series
based on the movie musical
"Grease"
that will take place four years
before the start of the film
when the students were still
in their early 30s.
The national weather service in
Florida
warned over the weekend
that the cold temperatures
could immobilize iguanas,
calling them to fall out
of trees and appear dead.
Experts added that residents
would only have a very limited
window to arrange them in funny
positions on their lawn.
I think we know they'd be
dirtier than that.
And finally, Krispy Kreme
has released
its Valentine's Day menu.
It's the perfect way to
literally win someone's heart.
As our monologue writer,
Mike Scollins,
who thought to himself,
you know,
the way to absolutely make
sure the last joke
in the monologue -- should note
that was the last one --
the way to make sure it lands
is end
with a picture of a man
in the hospital.
That way even if you don't get
the joke --
[ Laughs ]
That was a monologue, everybody.